this scene here is very high tech
there are guys in the military certain
groups around the world that can
absolutely do this
hi i'm kane vincent dyer i committed
over 100 bank robberies
in a period of of almost two years so
after turning myself in
i decided to form a coaching company
that helps people transform their lives
and today we are going to be judging
the authenticity of bank robbery scenes
in some of our favorite movies
he has on this helmet so he doesn't need
a mask
he doesn't look like he'd be coming in a
rob necessarily
it looks like he just kept his helmet on
which guys do all the time
i can really really relate to this him
wearing that backpack
i would sometimes either wear a backpack
or a duffel bag
strapped around the front and you can
still have the control of your hands
it's the only drawback if you get
any kind of tracker or die pack you walk
off
and that dive pack explodes he's wearing
it on his chest
this is so real it typically happens
your first time or two bank robbery is
bad enough so
just to put that out there and what we
know from watching the movie
is he's in a really desperate situation
sometimes the desperation
kind of overrides the moral compass it's
very accurate
it takes a second for him to pump
himself up
he has tape he doesn't want those gloves
coming off you know so obviously
he's really conscious of not leaving any
type of fingerprints
also it's holding his sleeve to the
jacket down
which could be covering up some type of
tattoo interesting that he picked a bank
with glass
because of the glass he's got to throw
it over to them
and you know they could put any kind of
device in that bag it almost shows most
more so the desperation that he went
into this bank that
is secure with glass and everything like
that but he was still so desperate that
it didn't stop him
him having a problem with his motorcycle
is something that's sure it's happened
they just blow through that red light
with all those cars coming
i don't think uh a intelligent police
officer would do that
just because you're putting a lot more
people at risk
i would actually rate this a nine
going into the bank leading up to the
bank preparing
getting nervous everything he did even
the mistakes he made
inside were actual mistakes that if you
you know you haven't done it you would
probably make
this vault that looks like no one could
ever get in except for
probably the us military we have to keep
in mind
that this movie everything about this
movie is supposed to be over the top
yes they do have very intricate
lock safes and things like that time
lock safes things that are really hard
to get into
but a lot of time during business hours
they will keep certain safes
open just so the employees can have
access
i learned everything so every bank i
went into
i knew whether it was going to have a
dave such as
the one that's in this scene or if it
was going to
be a regular open door
and if it were like this i would pass
unless i found in one of their manuals
or knew
that they would keep this door open
between certain times
could i get into that back then
where things were more manual oh yeah
i mean it it would have taken a
considerable amount of time to break
into that that's not like a three or
four minute
deal
you wouldn't have a weapon in there like
that unless you have a security guard
that was armed
you gotta keep in mind if you shoot that
shotgun and he hits that
bank robbery suspect those rounds are
probably
exiting the perpetrator and going
straight into the bank customer
or the bank employee what bus driver
that school bus doesn't have any damage
on it and he just crashed through
a cement and stone building and if you
remember it had to go
up the steps because when they robbed
the building they went up this step so
that
like totally hollywood right definitely
a one
the cameras already got them in uh you
know
on video so why even use a mask at that
point
either they should have gotten out of
the car gone straight in with the mask
on
or um not used anything
stay down we want to hurt no one
the energy is so on point how they talk
how they walk how they move
uh even the customers just the fear
that's there
cellophane money the money still wrapped
this is how a lot of banks will keep the
money when it comes in
because they're still coming from you
know basically the
bank factory 30. the silent alarm is
actually
going off as they're leaving
which is what employees are actually
trained to do
it's less chance of the cops getting in
there and then having a hostage
situation
the police are being alerted as the bank
robbers are leaving
which is super accurate i would actually
give it
about a seven the energy is so accurate
for
the bank robbers for that team you can
feel
the desperation that it needs to get
done
they know exactly what they're doing you
can tell by the way they move
where they go they know the layout of
this place
[Music]
bank robberies that are done by a lot of
different gangs
this is how they go in and this is how
they operate just with
brute force and sheer fear when's the
time lapse up for
nine o'clock it was it's a 15. he asked
her
uh something very specific about the
bank which he already knew
i would ask a bank employee a question
just because i knew the answer and i
wanted to see
if they were going to be straight with
me or not i wanted to see if they were
going to be nervous
how they were going to respond to the
question i was asking he just wanted to
see if she was going to cooperate
hold it silent this address you pulled
the alarm no
no a lot of people believe that everyone
in a bank you know all employees have
silent alarms that's
not accurate there's very specific
people
that have the silent alarms
that are allowed to push it
bleaching is something i haven't seen
done before
i know why he's doing it to get rid of
all type of evidence you know once you
put bleach on anything
everything just kind of dissipates it's
just interesting to me that they're
doing that like the gloves they they
have them so much that
covers them up i would say this movie
is a 10. for the realistic way that
these guys are just that aggressive
unfortunately
you have a lot of guys that go in and
that's how they do it
he's gonna kill us all unless
you can give me a giant
cash i have a plan
i didn't start robbing banks just to
because i wanted money i
started robbing banks out of desperation
in order to
pay off a debt that a very dear
relative to me had incurred to a
criminal organization
when people do a solo robbery and
they're trying not to be seen
this is exactly how they would approach
it they would hand
the teller a no they would probably
smile at people in line
we can say he makes the mistake of
showing his face
but most guys that go in solo like that
they often do that and they they hit
these smaller banks
and they just hope that the banks don't
really link up and they won't get that
much attention but they will go in and
show their
actual faces
you know someone's like why is she
moving that slow she's probably still
processing what they are trying to do is
try to give you
money that has some kind of detector in
it some kind of tracer
or dye pack
and we see the stack that stack looks a
lot
bigger it looks like something he should
take
it could be what they call the bait
money a stack
that bank employees have put to the side
and with those are the bait money
dye packs tracers here we see him being
captured on
video so when i did all of my bank
robberies it was in
the end of 99 going into 2000
you didn't have cameras that were as
high quality as they have now
so these old cameras used to be really
grainy
so they would have a lot of them but
it's very common to have the cameras
coming in
they're even things along doors that
will
allow a witness to gather even how tall
you are you'll see it in a lot of stores
or banks
and when someone passes it the employees
are trained to
look where he lines up on that
absolutely a 10.
absolutely a 10. there's no hold on
but you see the man with the briefcase
yes that's my partner
he has a gun in there if you don't do
exactly what i tell you or if you give
me any kind of a problem at all i'm
going to look over at my partner and
he's going to shoot
your mr guindon between the eyes i have
done that
i have gone into a bank and immediately
given instructions i've looked back
at the door from which i came in and
told an imaginary accomplice there
to make sure everyone keeps their head
down not lay down or hands in the air
but they keep their head down
like just their eyes focused on the
ground
and there was never anyone there take
one of those big envelopes and put as
many hundreds
50s and 20s as you can pack into it he's
disarming
her fear literally yeah
so it's not bringing any attention to
them that method
is a very very common method i would say
things like that even if i yell
louder and everyone else i would tell
the person that i was trying to get
to to do whatever i'm trying to get them
to do i would be much more calm with
them
versus screaming at them the rating i'm
going to give
this picture is a 10.
you know you would think he wouldn't
just go into a bank like that but
people will do things like that
especially if it's a smaller bank and
they think that the news isn't going to
travel any available units we have a
bank 211 in progress at the pico rivera
savings
that is super accurate where they're
trying to back down
other law enforcement the fbi agent that
was assigned to my case
patrick connolly he
changed how they went after bank robbers
and a lot of times they would just wait
for bank robbers to get caught in the
you know after the fact and they get
caught doing something else and someone
tells on someone
we've been surveilling these guys for
weeks that's what surveillance is they
commit a crime and then we stop them
the police aren't working together in my
case that happened a lot too
because other officers weren't giving uh
special agent patrick conley
the information he needed or they just
weren't used to chasing down
actual bank robbers anytime he heard
something come up he was always there
once that silent alarm was hit he'd also
go
[Applause]
i have never been in that situation
where i have been inside and the cops
have shown up
but i have been in the situation where
as i'm driving away
all the cops are coming into it the
moment i saw
all the cops i rolled all the windows
down
turned my music on and started singing
i'm gonna give it a seven
because today you know i think law
enforcement has learned a lot by not
communicating with each other
this scene here is very high tech
this isn't a normal bank robbery right
there are
guys in the military and um
certain groups around the world that can
absolutely do this now
a typical bank robber you're working
within a certain construct of time
and trying to get in a vault like that
even
if you have the skill set to get into it
it would probably take you
as long to get in that ball as the
sentence you would get for getting
into it i have gone into banks that have
safe locks and vaults and time lock
vaults and stuff like that
but there is a bank in spain that
operates in this way where if certain
parts of it are triggered
it will flood the actual safe
which holds all the gold i'll give it a
10 for entertainment
i'm gonna give it a one on
the skill set that anyone would have to
go
do that
i've been waiting to go into a bank and
i've seen a pregnant lady
or an elderly person go in
and it's made me either pause
or wait because i didn't want to
you know like i said a lot of people
when they do this they they
they're not thinking that they're
hurting the individual they're just
taking the money
you're putting a lot of psychological a
lot of psychological damage and trauma
on someone
uh sometimes you don't realize that in
the moment
just the one sonny right
this happened in 1972 in brooklyn
just a horrible situation when you have
this
hostage situation
[Applause]
right now he's in serious serious denial
i haven't been in this situation but i
remember
even before i turned myself in making
the decision that i wanted to turn
myself in there was just so much
back and forth with myself they got me
on kidnapping armed robbery they're
gonna bury me man
basically he's buying time we're working
off survival instinct
here now because he knows you can't go
anywhere but now it's just about
survival
i'm going to give it a 10. and were
there mistakes made in the bank
absolutely were there things that a
normal bank robber
wouldn't do in the bank yes but
in this situation all those mistakes
played into him getting caught
a lot of bank robbers especially
their first time or something like that
out of desperation they will just take
whatever they can put in and i've heard
about bank robbers going inside and
forgetting to take anything to collect
the money but
you know putting everything trying to
put everything in a t-shirt you know
he wasn't prepared for that which it
gave him pause
but then he had to jump back into his
into that zone of getting them out of
there so i like that they kind of
did that where they give him this human
quality like whoa
you know i didn't expect that because
he's just the driver
a situation that can definitely happen
the guy who's engaging them
has on has a marine corps hat on and
a marine corps decal on his car
and that was something that was always
on my mind
when going into a bank you know just
wondering if there's going to be another
guy in there like me
he was a marine like myself it happened
to me where i had a guy who was probably
former military or something
engage me come at me tell me to stop
and i followed the command i know it
sounds weird but i followed the command
because it just wasn't
worth physically harming someone for me
just that scene there that interaction
i would give it another seven we saw a
lot of violence happening
and it's easy from the outside to say
okay that wouldn't happen
but heck that happened
i've been into banks where during the
day where you see working crews there
but i would think that this would be
something where you'd have working crews
like that at night
but if you had to have them during the
day i could see how that guy could be in
there
everybody get down on the floor
i never used a team like that sometimes
people will get
a little violent uh unfortunately
and a lot of guys probably think that's
the way to instill
fear to get people to do what you tell
them but
kind of against that once again we're
looking at hollywood uh
i think would be much more secure than
that but a lot of old banks
did just have the glass doors later on
in probably like the
early 2000s what happened is you started
to see
banks incorporate this double door
mechanism what that was actually for is
to trap
bank robbers inside those first doors
that they went out of
i don't know if a bunch of serious
trained guys were doing something like
this this is probably the way they would
do it
so i will rate it another seven